now this podcast is over 20 before you
can start it with us oh you know what I
was gonna say let's do a show but now I
can't say that because you want to do a
show or no you want to do show I'll do
that let's do a show i'll do a show if
you'll just show all right that means i
got to turn this up and then i gotta do
this he's gonna work out
ladies and gentlemen straight back from
the state of New York straight back bat
full trot is joining us today on
Hollywood anonymous I am Brian her when
welcome
welcome I'm fry Darwin Hollywood
anonymous and I'm John oh there he is
sorry all right good take care of ya
this both hosts are here you ever have
teachers like wool way yes yeah oh wait
for John yeah well when you say that you
know mine was usually can you please
come up here cuz you're gonna be going
to the office really I got sent to the
office a lot too but they skip please hi
my favorite ones with me while my
favorite I kind of feel bad now cuz i
would go yeah go really bad now you do
comedy and get heckled what was I was I
did you get I don't get heckled I get
heckle up constantly well but and I
really feel from my teachers from the
7th through 12th grade but do you think
you get heckled because of your fan base
our because because Karma's coming back
at and that's what he's saying right you
say karma I don't know if it's Karma but
it's just like that's just part of the
job I think well it's definitely part of
the job I just part of the jump for you
so you get heckled constantly I mean you
do a lot of comedy well that's probably
the constantly part of it is he's always
doing comedy sway so he's a greater
chance I don't do it constantly bits all
lumped into one big 18-year pile in my
head right yeah so it feels like
constantly so technically over an 18
year period you could have been heckled
18 times and that seems like that's
still a lot honestly I don't even think
and you know I just open the door right
now and this isn't even real wood but
what's not heckled this year but it just
feels like i have the item i don't know
if it's it could not be easy to heckle
you for for multiple reasons one you
your self deprecating so that you're not
really attacking the audience and anyone
else our guest huh renounce i didn't
know i said straight out of New York
City you you were listening for that
part of it and then quit back into the
funny attack I said Matt voltron it was
actually kind of funny you go straight
back and he goes straight back oh yeah
at my head I'm like yeah stopped in
Cleveland without a fight about it it
was just in my head you had to do a drop
by know if it's time for me to speak yet
haha no um mean you've obviously been on
the show so you know the rule but I was
just going to bring you in from the
get-go because it's it's
it's that kind of date it's that kind of
day well your family to the show okok
all the family chat you think about it
you were there in the beginning I do
think about it was he number one are you
number one he was number one he hated
the title you gave him was it I get my
title tronic cocaine no no you
advertised it know that I i use the
tunnel i use the title that puts on the
thing oh because you didn't want people
to assume you did kokia we did have this
conversation yeah you see my family
listens to what I do the title no they
don't listen they were there are only
way the only retitle it says episode 3
matt fulchiron and cocaine yeah I didn't
have anything to do with that like Brian
puts the titles out but that that time
and then another one other time it we
had to change or we did somebody asked
if we changed the title for right oh
yeah yeah so now I check on the titles i
try to make safe titles no i don't
really care that's one of the few things
my family's already worried about that
type of thing really sure i don't worry
about you at all you see man you see me
get your act together I don't do cocaine
no no no you don't i don't think i
sniffed what I said that's good anymore
cuz i just ran out before i walked in i
used to do morning radio with a woman
that was that did quite a bit of cocaine
and everyone thought she would come in
you know cuz it with in morning radio
you gotta get like four thirty in the
morning so she's not even going to
sleeping right and she would come in
sometimes and and literally just be like
a bad 80s movie with cocaine around her
nose and I was like oh people really do
this in real life they had they don't
notice it yeah I thought there was just
a movie [ __ ] right like you know
slapstick comedy like you know throw a
bunch of powder on someone's face and
she acts you and said I'd be like nu-uh
blow your nose yeah website thing might
wipe it out babe your eyes are bleeding
you want to cut that out it happens
they're out there oh yeah I ran into
somebody tomorrow that was just like
really wanted to talk to everybody like
a chiffon me because I just don't know
how to be rude people isn't it easier to
root em when they're on coke mmm no but
they're not gonna take that hint so is
you either got to be straight up like
get away from me or you know what I mean
I've noticed it uh some younger comics
around the comedy store noticed that's
just making a little comeback it's
always making a comeback something
always supposed to be dead
it's always making a comeback yeah yeah
it I've never had it drugs are drugs for
a reason we were i was talking at so i
was talking at school in a big so true
but you know big bust on the street yes
they're hard to stop yeah big bus down
the street big bust yeah i was taking
the kids to school and you always know
when it's aight this is this is gonna
this this is the truth you always know
when it's a serious bust because um if
you see a cop getting out of like an old
beat-up minivan but he's wearing like
the SWAT best and stuff like that those
are like real deal life yeah yeah
there's these are sneak attacks yet this
isn't just the cops pulled up and knock
on the door right there expecting what
ential yeah and they're expecting
potential trouble so I drove past I got
up up top and then the mom there was of
course the mom there that live next door
to what happened yes they do early
morning with those types of rage they
know that you're probably sleeping
around six cuz you've been out until
four yeah and she had all these pictures
of just like tons and tons of assault
rifles laid out all over the street yeah
but it was a drug bust but it was a
marijuana drug busts and she's so
focused in the marijuana think they were
gang members but the point is all
weapons are we should be worried but
they were talking about the marijuana
and everyone's like haha this marijuana
I'm like you it this these guys just
remove that part of the product from
them if you're worried about it and just
go you know what we'll take this one
over we'll make it legal and then they
got one less thing that they can deal
with on the streets like that's the way
I look at it now the gun thing on the
other hand yeah that's the thing they
should be worried about a little [ __ ]
pot how would you worry about the fact
that these guys had a [ __ ] militia
yeah and we're not good people I'm not
keeping those guys when they're selling
those guns to people that are gonna do
other bad things with them as like hey
dad just these guys are going to the Boy
Scouts for recycling well then can't
kill you and when they one thing makes
you just super calm polite les vaya a
little bit hungry tired maybe creative
wrong focus focus on my shot I shoot my
enemy or should I take a nap yeah I do
feel bad tho bad man if I was raising my
kids accent and I saw that that would
freak the [ __ ] out of it with us all
yeah they knew something was going on
over there anyway but that's that thing
when you get into some of these this is
how
and park over there so you getting some
of the Highland Park still has its it's
right still checker box you know I mean
it's not know the hippest neighborhoods
in the world are the ones we can get
killed yep still have that little
element of danger yeah yeah it's got
this great gastro pub near me man but
also these guys with 45 assault rifles
the next door you lived you live in one
of those neighborhoods I don't know aber
hoods and um you know I should have
looked into it more but it was it was in
an area where i had lived it was only
like half a mile away from where I'd
lived before yeah but deadly say did
that happen I you know like south of the
10 or you go you know that mean roads
were always blocked off because they
were trying to find somebody that was
always helicopters I called in to
complain about it knowing knows one time
and they were like we heard gunshots in
your area i'm like yeah and just worried
about the nose the gunshots I'm used to
that I can sleep through that on any
given we lasted about nine months there
that was um I want to say la proper but
that was more Clayton heading towards
downtown right I'll ever forget where
you live off it was between here and
where I live now yeah so it was awful
Fletcher yes yeah and I know its massive
gang name on that water village uh very
affectionately towards Los Feliz
Boulevard right very ashamedly towards
Fletcher you lived in the Avenue gangs
area Mexican Mafia never made a mistake
oh yeah that was a very for a while that
was a very dangerous area yeah one of
the most dangerous areas in Los Angeles
they did they did the DA uh did a sweep
again middle the night sweep I mean like
a massive one was DEA FBI this is way
after you're gone but yeah FBI the
police went in there and I think they
rested like 55 people they did like a
sweep of that hole because it was
complete control over there my
girlfriend was watching the news one
time and you know saw the [ __ ] nice
be [ __ ] go right past our apartment saw
our apartment on them is that the one
with the guy shot the cop since of I
don't know what of course that was
always something going on over there a
speech speaking of well I was like in
Arizona just on the phone like yeah wish
I could help you know you're in there
I'm sure
I don't know what to do I don't know
what to do if i was there i wouldn't
know it yeah if i was there be hiding i
don't hella you want from me so how was
New York hmm it was great it was
fantastic oh really three months oh wow
look at that yeah we did it you did a uh
he does a really smart thing you did a
lot with somebody with a good apartment
Wow there you go I'm and then you re
they get orishas here mm-hmm then they
get yours yeah very much is in the kiddo
now that mines fine now no he's gonna
get pretty good now um but but still
like rent his place has got to be a lot
more expensive well yeah I didn't have
to deal with that that was the great
part of the deal was you pay your rent I
pay my rent but Los Angeles rent and he
paid in his Nujabes New York read this
it's a it's unbeatable deal cold smoke
where did you release that where was he
uh where does he hang his hat in New
York so well I don't spot but it's in
the East Village ok yeah and um so we do
you guys have both of you guys have a
date when i'm leaving and you're coming
back or sir very loosely we we we agreed
to in September and then you know as it
got closer to the date we we just
figured it out yet we agreed on it so
will you come home he's gears no overlap
that's what I mean there's no Matt and
re sitcom I wish there were but no there
was no uh it was it was all worked out
nice and clean did you work speaking of
clean did you keep the place clean I
didn't keep it clean but I clean the
[ __ ] out of it when I left I did that
thing where I and my apartment to like I
really cleaned it up for him and it's
just one of those things we like I don't
really want to go to New York now yeah
but you're saying it really clean the
apartment [ __ ] looks incredible he
didn't deserve this I didn't live in
letters also I know he's not gonna clean
it up as much from right I know he's not
did he I was pretty clean it was pretty
clean but I think I still might want I'm
not sure he probably tell you different
that cuz i do much effort he put into
his and you did a lot of staring up i
know you're on the river just talked as
you walked in you did some stuff with or
some road stuff with Ian yeah but did
you do some did you spend quite a bit of
quality time in New York City as well
yeah and how did that go tons of time in
New York City and it was fun because
you know they're not sick of me there
yet do you know what I mean like I've
been here for 18 years and everyone
likes me but it's like yeah of course
there yeah that's what he does yeah
that's it you know hey there was just
kind of like you know you mix it up with
new people new audiences blah blah blah
it was fun I enjoyed it a lot so I do
you still have a lot of friends back
there so you have enough I to hang out
with or is it a handful of friends and
uh you know I'm not the type of guy
needs company all the time anyways ok so
you don't mind doing shows by yourself
not knowing anybody on it just kind of
hanging out and then come in and go
always uncomfortable ok fair enough but
I still a comic brian has an uncountable
person right it doesn't make any
difference um but it is fun like I said
to like talk to people ooh you might not
know that well are you know you talked
to people just like so what you up to
there like nothing those who ooh but
don't but do you find that in New York
when your visit like your you know your
mat you live in LA you're there for a
few months people realize that about you
do you find that they're just they seem
more supportive or more I guess engaging
I don't know I felt like everyone's
really nice to me when I go to New York
and then the but if I were to move there
i feel like this [ __ ] guy again and
then they would just be like get out of
here you know there is that and this was
a very gray area was a three-month stint
yeah so I by the end of two months maybe
but I've gone there enough to that I do
have actual friends there and I don't
know I just I'm able to adapt to new
york rooms better now so I'm just more
accepted there nice nice do you uh have
you noticed it now because you've been
talking about doing it for 18 years so
when you go back now are you starting to
notice the age gap like we were taught
was it you have talked about the other
day we're like we're like wow the comics
are like a dude a lot younger and again
it's gonna happen but I don't notice
that when you go back it's very
interesting I think I think 30 is like
in 30 s is like the average age for like
the club comic yeah for the alt rooms
we're talking about twenties and yeah I
definitely notice it I'll be 41 so I'm
not that far above the average but I
definitely notice it especially when you
start talking to people
and like your arsenal of references gets
large yeah but they get less accepted in
a way cuz like it's like this than the
other and people like one you alive when
Nirvana came out there it is interesting
there's only certain things even even
when you're just talking comedy their
point of reference of what it was like
being in a comedy in some respects is
different than what we were experiencing
when we got into it too so it's like
there's certain things you can't even
relate to them about I had a 28 year old
co-host my podcast with me when I was
there and he didn't know [ __ ]
anything about like and some people
don't even know who Mitch Hedberg is
like it gets ridiculous wow the there is
yeah I always have but I John's getting
really uncomfortable oh no but I job but
I'm with you like it's really
frustrating but as we get older that
kind of [ __ ] just disarray and like and
because of how I was raised in my dad
was really into old commie like I
understand old county and I've grew up
with it and and I knew that I know that
that leads to this this and then I
followed stand-up I've always loved
stand up so I know who's who and who's
doing what and then you talk to somebody
today they're like no I just like jokes
think about what they have to keep up
with ya in one year yeah it's like
they're like this guy this guy this guy
this guy we had to like wait for the
rich inspire special to come on yeah and
you had to wait for it to come on and it
wasn't as much to keep track of because
a lot of people didn't make the spread
of a decade yeah whereas you know i
think mitch hedberg would really be
sticking out just as an example if there
was no internet he would still be
someone who's kind of celebrated but
it's late in the Internet age like let's
move on yeah let's [ __ ] him move on yeah
and even Netflix we've talked to I mean
there's so many Netflix specials now we
were growing up and not everybody was
doing specials you had to be special to
get a special like you had to rise you
know years in the club's rise up and get
to that point cuz it was only HBO I mean
eventually Comedy Central started doing
some stuff was more exposure but for a
long period of time it was Rodney
Dangerfield especially especially where
you get samples and then yeah or you had
to stay up late is your recording that
[ __ ] you had wanted why there's no way
to see it you know of that stuff so I
mean I kinda I kind of get that I with
the thing that's bothering me though
is we're starting to get this point
where we're dudes are just dying like
people that act like people that you
grew up watching are dying you know like
Gary shannon has a double August winter
yeah and Garry Shandling was like a big
deal I mean he wasn't that old and
granted he probably if he had made a few
better decisions within a 24-hour period
wouldn't be saying this about him but
it's just what is wrong he so he he was
having problems the night before uh-huh
and he called a friend who was a doctor
who said if you keep having it you know
deal with it tomorrow so it's kind of
money there was this window right like
maybe if and again may or maybe he still
would have died but the point being was
that if he was still having those same
breathing problems that ultimately led
to him passing out on the phone while he
was you know calling 911 and maybe if he
had just thought you know regardless
gotten up a little bit early just gone
somewhere if he had a wife he'd still be
alive probably yeah she would have said
we're going to the diverter nagged him
to death like 10 yeah yeah but my point
either like when some of these guys the
Robin Williams of the world you know
Garry Shandling you're starting to see
some of these comics die these are the
people that you grew up watching right
you know the Richard Pryor one didn't
have as big an effect just because he
had done so many drugs he was kind of
like a towards the end for him like he
really was like his own so everyone is
sick yeah yeah but you start looking
back on the influences and you start
going oh [ __ ] this is my parents already
went through this where the people that
they grew up what was it was five dog
Garry Shandling arm david bowie bowie
yeah Bowie was a big one Glenn Frey
didn't he go recently lemme lemme lemme
it was a lot when I was in New York
because you know it just sticks out as a
three month time period yeah a lot of
people were dying yeah and that's that's
when again you start going you go [ __ ]
all these people that were influential
in these worlds like that's this kind of
life but that's that I want to i went
into this bar this is you want to talk
about feeling old I went in this bar and
I was like a man five dog just died we
got to play some tribe called quest and
they were like no [ __ ] in New York
English they're not all New Yorkers in
New York especially in the east village
there the kids from wherever but dude
I'm a four year old white guy from
warrenville Illinois and I know who
Tribe Called
you were 20 when they came out yeah but
I'm not like I'm not like a massive fan
I didn't like their their bump it up or
anything the kids don't know about him
so are you saying that even hip-hop fans
I'm telling you so do i do you think
there's a disconnect um but I don't want
this this cover to get too serious but
I'm just curious like if you guys think
there's actually did a disconnect of
like music exploration meaning that like
it's more about the now less about how
we got there like more about
experiencing stuff and influences of
past first of all I don't think musics
as important as it was because um the
type of music is popular today
everyone's just kind of fine with the
fact that like a bunch of producers made
it and it's like very bubblegummy and
it's not necessarily very good music and
it to me it all sounds like like
especially the hip hop and pop it all
just sounds like all those who sued is
this my Steve Miller got pissed off it
just sounds like [ __ ] gibberish and
baby talk and um I don't know I don't
think it's that important and I don't
think um people keep up with her or care
about it as much do you think it's
because there's so much too much there's
so much more entertainment like musics
just like kind of one thing and it's
kind of meant to be played in the
background of a YouTube video and it's
just just like too much going on where
is um I know my generation was just like
it was one of the best things in the
world music was ever we would we would
spend our money on it still then we
would go we would go to great lengths to
get into it and you really identified by
what music you listen to it was way more
important than movies or anything else
from my generation no doubt about it and
I don't think it's that important and I
don't think people care as much and just
like we're talking about with like
someone like Mitch Hedberg people just
kind of like move on nowadays that's my
opinion I'm not until until target cells
image Hedberg t-shirt which will ya get
another gin you have to see that's what
I noticed that my my niece and nephew
started like they didn't point man I try
I think we may be talked about this on
the show before were like I would try to
sit them down and like play them cuz i
have a pretty big catalog of music in a
radio here's what i was trying to like
play stuff and like yeah yeah and then a
couple months later there they come up
and they're wearing
[ __ ] like Ramones t-shirts and pink
floyd I'm like oh they finally disguised
the [ __ ] fluence has were and the only
thing they discovered was on 799 t-shirt
at target it looked really cool yeah
they had there was no because these have
album covers back in the days all the
artists [ __ ] know exactly which by
the way that um i'ma get a t-shirt with
a thumbnail on it like like I like a
little 2 Chainz little 2 Chainz
thumbnail our Phil Hartman apparently
was a really well-known album art guy
you know that right like I said
little-known fact about Phil Hartman
which if you're under the age of 30 over
there like sometimes a wife can kill you
so I can go either way you know um what
what albums did he do cuz i know i
co-wrote pee-wee's big adventure yeah
i'll look at it while you guys talk
amongst yourself by but i know that he
did that's what he did he was like you
know like what guys we know now that
know how to do photoshop and grab ya I'm
giving Kevin um I can't think of his
name I'm no no forevers yeah I am
getting old you can doesn't ask you
about it you you keep getting these
people having writers to write and CI
does he do for does he do odds house
tons of money as an artist oh he does oh
yeah he's uh he's done like kings of
leon album covers he's done a lot are
you making stuff up right now i just
where the guy he hangs with the strokes
like this guy [ __ ] he's an artist you
know that i did not know oh yeah who's
doing all your stuff every time your
podcast is only getting new songs and
new logos and people see where do you at
all but how does that how did that all
evolve with you by the way that's it
like that that's that's an interesting
thing to me that you've got these people
that are sending you artwork for your
show or they're sending new songs about
your show yeah you cultivating that
stuff or is it actually happening
organically and were you surprised that
it happened that way I think I asked for
a theme song and like one guy made one
and that's the one we went with is the
winner of that contest no disrespect to
guerra plumber it's very good but uh oh
yeah and then somebody I went on the
bone zone and they know this guy that
writes a song about everybody so I got
that one that way that was nice this guy
puts out about ten songs a day his name
is uh uh paparazzi and um and yeah I've
only had two people make me songs okay
um okay what God world's if feel like
you get heckled all the time in my world
I'm assuming people are submitting songs
right
yeah they heckle me with t-shirts people
think t-shirt guns in my show and shoot
the mountain would be great you have to
boy got shot out a new suit at me I was
like ah dude thank you so much I needed
this all right so here's here's a Phil
Hartman's album cover stove album did
poco a song set are the band seven but
and then these this is the 70s America
the band America oh I heard that much
yeah he did to him though name crosby
Stills and Nash all right uh the fire
sign theater fighting clowns okay amor
America so he did a lot of America a lot
of poco Latin America Steely Dan Wow
okay so that's some of stuff interesting
that some would have liked did the you
know to a legacy like that or like two
different lives in a way yeah well any
but you one of you guys alluded to it
but I mean album artwork is actually I
mean I put albums up mine a little more
kooky but I know nanny um chick to chick
but some of them are it is amazing art
and I think that enemy but you don't
need that again because the digital era
do you really need to do that anymore do
you really need an irrational attention
you're wasting your time with that you
need to put out a full-on [ __ ]
documentary you gotta go all out you do
have to have art on some level because
you gotta do billboards and stuff like
that i also think just if you if even if
I you know you put out a CD and even if
it's not like a CD it is just like a
thing the picture that comes up on
iTunes or whatever you have some not
have something there you know what I
mean and it should reflect I mean I I
don't know I would want it to be good
like I you know I like I like the
artwork to be good no matter where it
yeah so and you know I never once that's
subjective so but I think no you're
right you still have to have one it
still has to be good and it still has to
you know represent what you do but back
in the day it was just like you had to
[ __ ] you would look at it whenever
you played the album so yes true dude
and looking at all the set hours an hour
lyrics on it you'd have the set up right
then if there was no picture of the band
you just had to wonder what the band
look like most favorite album cover that
you looked at the most growing up oh wow
probably just go Mickey Mouse disco
Mickey Mouse Mickey Mouse put out a
disco album and everybody had a track
like Donald Duck had one goofy had a
track I listeners nut
and then there was the was a good album
cover like yo-yo yeah like Saturday
fever but like me I was dressed in John
Travolta suit yeah exactly yeah yeah it
looked like said yes and I don't mines
gonna be generic but I was always fasten
this is very early on I was fascinated
by the elo album were you opened it up
and turn into the skull you know they
had you guys own time I said was that
one too because some of them actually
were like it wasn't just you opened up
one thing is like opened immutable
things I was like a boost it was a dead
the interactors yeah it was interactive
so I was always fascinated by the yellow
one I was gonna say something but then
what what Matt said it made sense
because like what would i look at the
most was when I was a child I would
listen to like these Superman records
that were like storylines and like oh no
those are my kids every night I I found
him on youtube they they go to bed to
those they're awesome but I would stare
because it was like you know you're
looking at the picture on the front with
Superman and on the back there was a
bunch of stuff so and then i had a
couple popeye records that i listen to
what but then like I would say when I
got into I remember when I first saw the
album cover for there's a do album was
it called afraid of the dark no that's
RFD listen to that yeah but I had never
list I had never listened to do and my
friend my best friend's older oldest
brother was like hey want sooo cool
album cover and he showed it to me and I
was like oh that's terrifying what is it
was like maybe was like under from under
the bed it was something like was creepy
under the bed something and like I was
like that's scary and then my friend had
a picture disc for an Iron Maiden single
and it was um oh god I can't remember
but I'll mascara yeah but you know like
a mummy they're more in the mummies well
I Eddie that was Eddie is their guy and
then he they wrap them in a mummy they
make him enough space alien they make
him a monster they make him all these
different things on the first Albie's
actually a murdering rapist but like
when you move on from the kids cuter
after the heck it's cute yeah there's
nowhere to go except up but yeah I would
say like some iron maiden but like also
i remember getting that i got bought
tapes in fourth grades well that's what
I was gonna say I Wesley by the time I
really got into music it was taped yeah
so check this out so I get that is the
phrase to pay
there's a billion dollar tapes the it is
that we've we just accepted this part of
the show drivers I got the eater this
will this i watch connected everything
is like constantly doing things all of
the place without my control I jive
given us your dick tracy lifestyles
right yeah speaking of that I i met the
Warren Beatty I should have I should
have talked into my iphone in front of a
recipe to reactive but then I didn't
also wanted to be make it any more
awkward than it was already going to be
and he might have forgot he did Dick
Tracy while you were out of town yeah
that's exactly why we go now we spent
about seven months on that and then it's
just out of his head if seven months so
uh guess guess while you were gone yeah
The Herald opened up for a day get the
[ __ ] out of here only the lobby uh-huh
for our man our favorite friend you and
I are sports anger that's right go so I
to try to top you in awkward Arnold yes
finally someone steps up tonight on
awkward on the team man I knew that face
is going out of business it's so so to
awkward things happen what's worse a
[ __ ] oh my god this is a gift from
heaven he had this year so alone in the
world for so long specially after I had
lectured you to never get involved in
awkward situation I've never seen one
someone smirk from the back of the head
it was humiliating so I got stuck in the
wrong spot on set uh-huh he had to do
this you know the pace please God no no
one told you to get down he had to walk
back and forth to do this thing uh and
he his landing spot was always right in
front of me staring directly at me ah
but I didn't want to look at him so like
i see like a sad dog i would just put my
head haha he was stand like a foot and a
half of me and I think he knew that was
making me feel awkward so he got into it
even more horse horse he did cuz you
know I wouldn't do it was doing it I
would do is having fun without Adam and
I was like back with me but I was just
imitating people i got stuck in the spot
I didn't need to be there was you know
sometimes you get on set and you can't
it's too late you can't get
out the thing is the way that the set
was built there was no escape route from
behind the camera uh-huh you had to go
past camera in order to get out you the
opolis you could have been yes well okay
hold on come on The Herald goes back
into business and they call you in for
the day yeah yeah was it yeah okay all
right who was the horse like it well
they gotta close to God yeah was good
money was good so he did so then I
thought I'd get some good but I wasn't
the only one working so Eric and dejuan
I brought a whole crews but I brought
the band back ok so those guys were
outside right so eventually they stop
filming Schwarzenegger leaves and goes
back to his trailer out front right so
then I I leave of course I get out there
and Eric's like let me show you what I
got what do you think Eric showed me a
picture Hitman's hidden sports integrin
anyway new farming yeah exactly and then
jiwan's like I got one too and I was
like you know I never asked for oh [ __ ]
for pictures and it seems like he's
giving him away today I'm nervous now
yeah give it away and eric is like don't
worry about you know I'll go let him
know that you're our boss and that you
never asked for pictures and he goes
over there and and he talks to sports
integra security guard and security
guard is like who like looks over it
just gives me like [ __ ] won't you
people leave me alone so now it went
from like everybody was okay for here in
pictures we're now I can say that they
can go we should have never opened up
this [ __ ] gate in the first place yes
because now people are just going to
know why you always told them not to do
it yes so then Eric comes back he goes
no I talk to him I told me I think it's
gonna happen so he goes he'll talk to
him in then when they come out to the
car who come over get a picture with it
would have been worth it just so you can
send it to me exactly see what you do if
you play your cards right so we just
stand by the car they walk out they walk
right past me get in the car and get the
[ __ ] out of it was so humiliating I was
like yeah and the dude that like the
security guard kind of like made like a
[ __ ] adjustment you know like st. hat
yes sir it's not happened you didn't
really wanted to bed no now you're here
to you that security guard never said
[ __ ] the swartz ago and i'll ask him
i'll talk no ball plate we've all been
there we are like don't worry about him
and I'll totally say something just like
is that it was the security guard has to
be the pain in the yeah and you
like please don't ask me from pay as
soon as he said who Eric should have
known right there it nevermind just drop
the surprise it's not [ __ ] happening
that's Eric as important as if source
seems like oh yeah totally that one guy
yeah let's get that picture let's go
ahead I feel for you still not as bad as
mine I don't know I that's one of those
moments and I have so many where I think
about it i'll just be alone i think
where I go Oh Justin myself especially
when they're that recent you know me
like what you do it doesn't matter well
I mean I've done stays planted with all
these mistakes hey but listen I still
got our cigar hanging out back you know
the sort entire thing about my new aha
my day that's right so you Arnold that's
right I've got to be CEO gonna sample
your DNA and make it clone you I might
just inject some time I see if I get
some muscle on it I've never seen that
movie pumping iron but isn't all about
him like just [ __ ] with lou ferrigno
it's I know they're in competition
together it's the two of them yeah in
that movie he smokes a huge joint on
camera and like since is like that I eat
steaks and like it was weird but yeah he
does kind of [ __ ] with lou ferrigno the
whole time but i like lou ferrigno comes
off pretty cool in that movie yeah I
like that movie pumping iron is a good
movie I heard it's great yeah I gotta
watch it I got ya it's entertaining it's
I gonna put my differences aside to
watch anything out of them you pick a
side view you were a freak no guy or
your sports singer guy you had no now
definitely Lou Ferrigno oh it's like Lou
furring I you know I like the Hulk Hulk
was good he was a hero to me as a kid
not Arnold I was never like Augustine
new Arnold movie so with the friggin
thing the frig no think so he Canada
mera one night and I but so he came to
the Herald but I let Tanner meet him
uh-huh cuz I heard he likes kids like he
like Oh kids kids are so cool yeah he's
done a safe at you yeah you get in there
creepy adult take the adult who used to
be a kid who thinks you still like looks
at you like the Hulk he not a fan of
those people probably as much I'm just
I'm of course I'm guessing assuming that
that's the case I was not told that yeah
but soda Juan took uh Tanner in to me
blue furry Lou Ferrigno so Tanner still
talks about that which is funny cuz I'm
like Tanner's like well I've met the
Hulk Elliott and I'm like you have a ten
have you seen any of the Hulk episodes
because I we haven't even showed me a
well no but I'm just letting you know I
know he's the Hulk and
so I've met the Hulk and he's right
technically he's met the whole if kids
saw that Hulk they would never stop
laughing oh my gosh he was painted green
can you imagine baby great hey watch the
new adventures and then they watch the
series like what happened in the Hulk
what's going on he doesn't jump you know
it's like a regular dude and green bank
of the larger bodybuilder with a bad wig
just kind of run emotion yeah yeah yeah
i believe i'm not mistaken all the hulk
stuff was in slow mode no I mean and
even in Iran I think when he went yes
jame to look better you know and even as
a kid you going it ripped his pants but
not the waist part Yeah right and then
he just happens to find clothes that fit
him in a ton a clothes line every time
you like all right I remember my mom
liked you she would never watch it with
me but it always be honest she hear in
the background and at the end of that
episode when he starts hitchhiking again
do-do-do-do namaz I got that is such a
sad song it really is the guys like you
know isn't it jakey it's so sad it's
like he's got to move on man tragedy the
end of everything is like at red because
you can't I thought I was gonna be fine
here yeah but the goddamn Hulk got out
again because his people make me to God
a man yeah yeah yeah yeah and look mr.
McGee you won't like me when I'm angry
and didn't my favorite episodes were
always when there was another Hulk
ahhhhhh there was a it what he wasn't
was a green though he was a low off he
wasn't sleepy girl right is a gray hole
he's maybe blue or something and was it
wasn't Lou Ferrigno now some other guys
some other I think that we look like a
really big um William Dafoe oh hey
hideous but like that kind of jaw so
somebody else who would like gotten too
much gamma radiation or whatever yeah
yeah but they didn't like each other for
some reason do you think they'd be like
I'll finally somebody there Hulk cool
let's go drinking like bucks not at all
right let's not get an argument let's go
eat some ass start a gang let's take
over the world which would be like you
think somebody turning the Hulk is
terrifying two guys turning the Hulk I
feel like there's even more of them just
good thing they run in slow motion cuz
we gotta get the [ __ ] out we got
get away and climb trees they're like
bears and why do they change his name to
from Bruce to David Banner I don't know
why they did that it was there something
that like there's been a couple care to
do it with the flash to right where they
get the flash has two different but then
but it's actually possible the flash i
think was two different characters I
think I can't remember that one there
must be something well that much i
didn't even know cuz i didn't read the
comic books for the Hulk or anything so
when the when the first movie came out
i'm like why they keep calling this guy
Bruce right I was like this doesn't make
any sense and they're like well you know
I might so Mike Witt is he the dad of
David Banner like I'm and there's no
google you're just left to [ __ ] him
Conda haha bothering it's not gonna be
in your botanical yeah I did change it
why didn't they yeah Rogan told me it
was because Bruce was a [ __ ] a gay
name I was gonna ask that cuz it used to
be that's that that was their theory
that's Joe's theory and he sounded like
he Joe always sounds like he knows what
he's talking about you never like nah
Joe you like yep what do you guys think
about different are the same actor
playing two different superhero
characters well I be absolutely illegal
should've been doing a McDonald's in a
burger unacceptable I don't I'm not even
a calm I don't even like those movies
but it's not still like on except
they've done twice now correct Batman I
mean Ben Affleck was to character devil
in Batman it wasn't right what so go
ahead get go ahead and then Ryan
Reynolds was two characters man what out
Green Lantern and Deadpool yeah and
wasn't dude um uh Fantastic Four and
Captain America I think so yes he was
that idea Johnny Flynn do not accept
this yeah you're right yeah flame on
yeah for the full of us for the waters
to with uh we are Jessica Biel and IV uh
oh Jessica I glad you guys feel that way
cuz I've brought up to so many people
know just go yeah that's fine just like
but it's like um the best one I can
understand because the dirt devil thing
came and went so a leg was such a dud
but the other ones were pretty close
together on top of it what I'll say
except you know you not have access none
of this okay my whole thing is if
there's no one at your theory that I
don't even find anybody else I'm just
like no like you know you gotta believe
this guy is 10 and this guy's another
hero all right Ron but the but it's such
a remake culture they don't give up
about your memory made how much only
proved wars have there been right how
many spider may have their [ __ ] [ __ ]
only proves my point that like people
don't keep they can't keep up with the
past yeah they only can go they only go
with the current because there's too
much current so it's toby mcguire
already a classic no yeah well I use
that third movie he made was so bad that
that's why they read they were like well
well no but I mean like wood wood Tobey
Maguire's the Tobey Maguire spider-man
is that considered an old classic
Spiderman because Navy it's old that 10
classic but it's definitely old because
they're been to other ones in between
the made in the 2000s correct all those
remain the 2000s there has been there's
nothing is from the 90s I also can't
deal with the new Batman who used to be
dared like a new first of all new Batman
I've already seen for Batman's in my
life and if I have to see another put
any more footage of his parents getting
shot in alley like yes like we know we
know be they do that we can made a TV
show with his no Batman yeah god but
it's Batman [ __ ] all y'all [ __ ] you guys
man we gonna say before I kenyatta I was
gonna say the the Ryan Reynolds thing
like I well I one I didn't have any real
problem with green lantern everyone
hated that movie I thought it was okay
it was entertaining whatever but um
Deadpool was awesome okay and I you know
I don't I'm sure other people could have
played that character but he also played
he's a funny guy he's a very funny guy
but he played dead pool in a Wolverine
movie and it was a quick thing and they
didn't do Deadpool correctly and people
like what that guy was supposed to be
dead pool so in the new movie he makes
fun of the green lantern and his I heard
that yes to him from the other thing
it's very tongue-in-cheek like I take
that you know that's like oh that's like
a point back you know yeah it was like a
wink and nod you know what we're doing
oh that's [ __ ] up and if he had his
way cuz he's been trying to get the
Deadpool movie made forever haha so if
he had his way he would have never done
Green Lane are they would have done
Deadpool but what was wrong with his
Deadpool in the wolverine movie that I
guess the mask was weird he didn't I
couldn't talk and then it was a quick
that right was like a quick weird way
like a silent fight on it was really
quick yeah but he's known for
wisecracking but he couldn't talk in a
woman that's the thing yeah and his and
his thing was all his costume was all
messed up but now they're talking about
like Deadpool and spider-man doing a
thing together and just spider-man's on
loan
from to do this x-men I just don't know
why I'm still supposed to like super
hero buried under say one you're so
confusing cuz that's all the superhero
movie got or what [ __ ] I actually got
over that [ __ ] when I was a kid I was
like now I'm in a skateboarding and punk
rock piece well but see here's the thing
so super mirror superhero movies like
look at it from my kids standpoint yeah
superhero movies are what westerns were
to us as kids growing haha is [ __ ]
all westerns bad that was it it was like
apparently that's the only thing that we
[ __ ] make is westerns cowboys and
Indians right this is cowboys and
Indians now this is how they're doing it
this is the only thing they make ya got
its wits the only thing but I feel
people go see in theaters do you know
what I mean like I'm sure and even for
myself like am I gonna go see a
low-budget drama in a theater no I'm
gonna wait for that to come on HBO and
watch it from my couch yeah make phone
calls and fix myself to meal exactly do
right not watch drink cheap beer go
ahead whenever I want I actually have to
go watch the art movie in the movie
theater because otherwise I will not pay
attention to it at all cuz you have too
many things it does the [ __ ] phone
and the [ __ ] spaghetti and meatballs
I'm making [ __ ] boy or do you or not but
I could get you guys done the ipic
theater yet I pic yeah that's where you
get the recliner that's with a clockwork
orange your ass and your ice pick um
they know I picked you it's uh you get
recliner seats a full menu they serve
you you can order beers we're watching
what about theater yeah go into a food
coma I'd be blacked out before the movie
it's a little bit dangerous if they're
serving on alcohol you do have to be
careful because you can drink there's
like a full bar right out like so you
don't i've done it was one right on my
block when I lived in Williamsburg ok
for year three years ago and uh it's
[ __ ] great i love it i mean you spent
a hundred dollars yeah very expensive if
you go see a movie in 3d and i'm
actually spent close to a hundred and
you get food and i take someone with you
you spent close to a hundred dollars
anyway I've been avoiding me i feel like
the imax is just too much [ __ ]
information for me now 3d and imax i
haven't seen anything in it I saw Star
Wars there i saw this i saw the news by
superman batman actually star wars was
the first movie I saw 2d on a regular
screen when it came out for like ever
because usually it's all been imax 3d
which is fun
and then have you ever gotten the seats
that move no they never done that I did
it but I did it for the Martian for some
reason and then the whole movies Hurley
through space and ever do you like was
like actually drank occur after like
five seconds I was like we made a huge
mistake with this this is way too much
it was just it was pointless is making
you nauseous yeah this wasn't it was
annoying it was just like somebody
poking you the whole time you like
outright the only thing I can't watch in
movies I don't like spinning in films at
all and so like the space movies there's
always someone we're like yes space you
loo you get unconnected and you spin in
spit like any of that stuff or the guys
I was or when you get listing they test
you if you can go to space or not
there's video around or before see you
need a drink like you know god no I was
vomit on everybody if they did that
because I had vertigo one so i can't i
have that's i'm done that stuff i can't
do anymore at all i remember which no
one really just forgettable movie but
they member ski they made a speed racer
movie yeah i do how we had like the
walk-on sisters made it what are they
yeah yeah that's what they are the
walk-on cystica whether the name there I
don't know what there was a sisters or
brothers now they're sisters all the
Wachowskis yeah other sisters now you
know they're both sisters both sisters
now the other one just recently indeed
oh no actually both sisters now not just
one of them with eight wins I don't know
I don't know enough about they still are
if they were what yeah is this is yeah
yeah I'm talking about it like they're
gonna do a past life but ya know I but I
don't for real if they would be
interesting if they were twins because
maybe like 23 years they weren't twins
right then now the twins again well no
they weren't identical they can still be
twins is that I tell you they were
identical it were you saying they got
turned into fraternal twins but that's a
weird word to his fraternal is very male
I don't know what we're gonna say just I
can't watch speed racer not that anybody
should we watch it watch that movie yeah
but i had a new think of his screen i
had to [ __ ] turn it off there was too
many colors and like too much like
racing and doing loop-de-loop things i
literally had to [ __ ] turn it off as
i reminded me more when they're tell all
the kids got um um had convulsions from
watching I'm Chung video though no like
Teletubbies ER Teletubbies the [ __ ] is a
the little yellow rabbity looking thing
pokemon pokemon cartoons the kids were
all going we're having fits from
watching am anyway you need to eat is
that we are you have it are you crashing
oh that look how you can eat you're like
oh I said you want to eat your Apple eat
your Apple your gear can t DiNapoli
John's got his worker man lunch out here
all of a sudden he's doing it he's doing
it right sorry John brought food to be
full sorry John McCauley diver beside
who had it's a temple Brent about his
true it was a cave yesterday it was a
cooper today it was need to live out
autumn hit over the weekend so now it's
a temple I was uh so you said you got
back a week ago yeah how are you are you
adjusting ok to Los Angeles why it's New
York crazy to sell jelly are you a
Bernie are you a Bernie or Hillary guys
New York is New York just all lit up
about Bernie and Hillary over there did
you see rocky oh that's Philadelphia uh
I saw Creed I so pretty nice I don't
know who the [ __ ] to vote for and I'm a
little bit bored since I've been back
I'm not bored I've just been like doing
my taxes and dealing with real life that
I was putting off yeah you know so there
there is that to factor in the equation
also to buy a car because my car got
smashed right before I went to New York
oh yeah that's right yeah yeah you were
an accident or someone hit someone hit
it Oh and so I gotta take care of that
too you know it's almost like she's
gonna [ __ ] farming but like I don't
like making drastic decisions in my life
anymore I like to just ride the wave
well if you did that though I mean New
York's a lot more expensive than LA
right so you're already gonna go back
into a you're gonna if you decided only
thing that's expensive in New York is
rent what thats that in itself with so
how much more like so how much more like
a couple hundred bucks more month I've
looked at places that were yeah just a
couple hundred okay okay and then like
and you can get anywhere you want for
like 2074 sense it's ridiculous man
Uber's big out there too right or no no
yeah they got it they're not get is here
don't know the last time I was in an
uber New York was two years ago and the
guy was like I go I yeah it was great
you know it's a little cheaper goes dude
where are you from I go Los Angeles he
goes yeah I'm sure in Los Angeles is
cheaper do but you better off taking a
[ __ ] can also capture cuz there's so
much competition i have this only time i
take cabs or
were on the airport okay and that's just
like a you sell your subway guy that's
just a straight luxury for me yeah
subway of course you walk away
everywhere yeah walk I take the subway I
walk across a bridge I go nuts i love it
i love you have no problem going along
no no problem but how was the weather
when you were there though it was not
walk it was cold but i just didn't
bother me i don't know i had a jacket
everything was fine you walk everywhere
when you go there is everything yeah i
mean a little i'm not like i will take
the train and stuff but i just don't
like one or ground it's hot there's so
many people so when it gets hot its
discussed it is cold when compared to
hot oh yeah dude it I've only ever
walked in New York I don't I walked
three miles to the stand for my
brother's place to do a spot because I
was like whatever three miles [ __ ] it
and that but here I like won't walk down
the street to go the gym exactly I'm
gonna go drive to the truck seems like a
longer walk cuz there's nothing to look
at and no one else is watching someone
else is walking on the street it's like
a half a mile like are we gonna say hi
yeah there's so many people in 20
seconds are we gonna say hi and the
answer is usually no you used to where
you live do you walk down to all those
stores down there or were you getting
your car and driver there I usually walk
because it kind of kills my soul a
little bit to drive there ok but if
times of an issue which it never is
basically if I'm starving to death I'll
get in the car ok that's a shitty drive
to a starving to death car that has a
sandwich in it yeah that's what I like
it so you get into a car that's like
delivering pizzas I'll get into this car
yeah exactly I'm hungry so where all did
you go when you uh when you would you go
on the road whatever Liberty High I
really only went to the Albany funny
bone and the Syracuse funny bone ok how
was ours they were they were they were
good yeah it's your your regular
run-of-the-mill uh in a shopping mall
funny Mon they look exactly that's a
funny button they look they all look
exactly the same but they're both pretty
fun weeks and those did you pick those
up after you went there you already knew
you had those so when you went out to
New York those were already part of the
plan went there with with nothing really
set up I really didn't do any planning
till I got there ok it didn't seem like
a real trip in my head until I got there
yeah well I better [ __ ] do something
all I'm here
you know other than drain your bank
account so yeah just you know just walk
around which I love to do but after a
while like your work ethic kicks any
like I should probably do something you
know I should probably make this
worthwhile but then the other side of
that is like all right I'm just going up
like you know you got me to do mostly
free shows and stuff yeah I did like
what is this even you came out for free
show you my somewhere else Avery
freesias you know you get paid sometimes
but for the most part it's just like
yeah this shows really hard to get on
and then you get in there and it's in a
basement window stage and it pays dick
yeah face dicks I 0 how was this hard to
get on why should one clamoring to get
on it is also a lot of this is the best
show in the city really need some work
yeah you uh huh so how did you handle
your podcast for three months and with
with Coleman and Wendell still doing it
right to go to Wendell's yeah I gotta um
I got co-hosts and I did a lot over the
phone a lot of owners okay and it was
not near as good as it usually is that
my theory was keep doing it every week
because that's what it's based on if you
yeah it's not based on quality at all no
stop and people like oh we don't know
podcast more than their to go to start
from scratch yeah so my theory was just
turn the recorder on and see you know
maybe you don't do an hour this week but
I did and always there's always some
laughs on it so [ __ ] it so you took all
your stuff with you yeah all of it or
just some of it I even traveled up to
all of it I even traveled up to Albany
with it in my suitcase one time okay me
and Ian did an episode okay so yeah I
kept doing it and where did you said
where did you go with bag you went to
Canada I did a show in canada in january
with him we're at up in his hometown I
forget what it's called Harris yeah
that's it so that was missable I can't
imagine two terraces have a comedy club
no it's some kind of benefit that IAM
runs okay and and it was a really great
show in this huge school auditorium okay
so i was a pretty well attended it was
it was sold out nice Wow except for the
[ __ ] we had to kick out so well what'd
you at the kick-out it was great this
girl started heckling me during my thing
so yeah okay it did happen this year
[ __ ] sorry to bring
it up with you on the show were you
first no I was it was erected date was
there somebody that kind of hosted he
and hosted oh he did oh I was first but
I went in probably like 20 minutes in
okay what it was not hold open no no no
no so I went up there and um as well as
the audience's on your side and I
ignored it for a good 10 minutes so
that's kind of a good move because then
the audience gets sick of that person
they're annoyed that she's really out
there trying to watch a show and so one
point she like couldn't handle the
silence in between a pause one of the
jokes and I just [ __ ] squashed her
ass so hard it didn't matter what I said
everyone was ready to be like yeah shut
up yeah then she came back and then I
just crushed or even hard and harder and
then he went out and he started fighting
with her and then uh it's like that seen
an airplane like everyone's waiting for
that a guy with a garlic uh and then she
gets kicked out and then right after
that they did a lottery and she won well
she did win but she wasn't there I swear
to god of course the loudmouth wins the
lottery at this point you start to
believe in karma I know you asked me
that earlier yeah honey so we just the
two of you guys know it was me it was
Francisco Ramos okay uh and it was a guy
named Chad Daniels out of all we don't
you why don't ya I started with Chad
bags a good guy he's a funny guy I think
I like I don't shed Daniels I don't know
one he's really funny and he well you
know if I don't know how many [ __ ]
Conan videos you watch but he's going on
Conan and he's been on TV a bunch and
stuff so um so everybody flew up there
for this this event on Terrace is not
what that's it's a hall right above
Edmonton it's a huge hall and I had to
take three flights there at three
flights back whoa um I got stuck in I
did this look what was it Louisiana New
Orleans comedy festival which is kind of
[ __ ] wait wait about you went to gare
all the way down into warrior i went
from New York to New Orleans and that is
because it was a comedy festival yeah is
this the one that you're surviving
it was this elaborate please just want
to give women and minorities discounted
entry fees nah-uh it was it just wasn't
that great ok so I want to [ __ ] on it
they do have good comics there if you
live there if I could go there support
the goddamn festival right but it's very
like kind of thrown together ok so
there's more than one festival it sounds
like that takes place down there is that
was ever st. John ah yes I'm okay but
this one's actually called the New
Orleans film festival I got the old
festival in puzzles no did I say film
yeah New Orleans comedy fellow ok so
then I go then I was supposed to go to
back to New York but it was snowed so
then I went to [ __ ] Washington than
Vancouver than terrace ok and it was the
same way back except i ended up in New
York you flew into terrorists 3 i'm
assuming i know so puddle jumper by the
time i got to tear that the last one was
like a puddle-jumper teeth terrorists
how big is terrace it's not that bad
it's not big at all the whole town was
at the show no they weren't no it's just
sorry I was yours basketball baby no it
sounds like northern exposure all of us
asked or is it like northern exposure
yeah okay it was funny cuz en gave us
the like the tour in the car so he's
great otherwise you guys in it you guys
just drove around the school well we
went to the gym at one point and so yeah
we actually went in the high school
because his friend was a principal at
the high school that's hilarious you
know you no alcohol at this event right
so there you got a heck you gotta sober
heckler yeah that's how disturb this
person huh [ __ ] bizarre unless she
did her unless you did a parking lot
duty she could have done that that's
maybe that small town [ __ ] exactly I'll
been there you should all better center
I'm gonna do guys I was gonna say I just
hit at the palladium and blacks out
before Lamb of God where else did you go
you said you went somewhere else I
really didn't go anywhere else I stayed
in New York and I did as much shows
though yeah all right and you're just
glad to be back so now what are you
gonna do here you gotta crush it seems
bored dude he's doing his tax on out but
he's got the future here the future is
here while you get to your normal vodka
pictures you can just see Wendell the
podcast is so easy since I've been back
it just flows like so well you know and
then we and then we have awkward silence
on this one okay we're just kidding I
was trying to keep it going yeah uh yeah
it's like it's good at that that's the
best part about being back is getting
back with the old
yeah because it just goes I want to put
that much effort into it it's just like
it just goes whereas like I was kind of
stressing a little bit because here and
there you'd hear somebody be like a moon
yeah poor kisses good New York yeah oh
listen to 55,000 other podcast jackass
so you still like you still like losers
right yeah oh you got to be got out of
New York okay good used to like doing
the podcast I do I you know how many
episodes of you win I'm 177 in and I
mean Q only only ask is you and I have
over the years of just kind of talked
about like where were like what is it
where does it go like do we do it where
I go this is I don't really feel like
doing this every week you know I think
it would be better if I didn't do it
every week that have something to talk
about for a [ __ ] hour right but at
the same time I'm like uh I feel the
amount of work i have to do as a
comedian or actual work product I feel
so bad if I didn't do this one little
thing yeah that that you talked for an
hour every week with your friends yeah
eat a piece of pizza you [ __ ] you
guys on your chili pizza from my guys no
disrespect none taken i guess no you
know I don't do it all the time cuz I
didn't do it for you there we go okay so
good good I was just trying to make it
sound like it was fun uh and it's mostly
fun recorded a carnival it's only not
fun when it when it becomes inconvenient
you traveling you're doing this like
when I was stuck in New Orleans an extra
day and I still had to do it that's the
other thing I still feel like I have to
do it yeah there's this little like I'll
get guilty if i don't do it yeah i mean
and i also just don't want to hear about
it i guess i could not check twitter i
did that for a week i was really it was
great it was great because i just didn't
have like these outside not that i get a
lot of hate or anything but just these
outside just extra outside [ __ ] was not
coming my way i really enjoyed it and i
don't know why i can't stick to it
because i really enjoyed it and your
numbers are still going up right i mean
so you're still building on I mean
you've always had good you bet it you
gotta
good size of caster sugar you get
feedback like we don't get a ton of
feedback on our show we've never do it
as positive positive yet to be clear to
be clear I've never missed a week for
three years while and so I've got people
that are that are into it and do do
people think the best episode ever was
when me and Brian made yeah I Coleman
cry because he believed in sasquatch yes
yes they do so bizarre that was awesome
that was great I still was like that was
a yeah that was on my podcast because
like I was in your pocket we had talked
about pasta did we ever have the makeup
episode yeah we had Craig on UK we did
and you came on Monsignor that's right i
want to talk about yes you ready for at
idate he was more embarrassed than
anything else well then he cuz he was
duty was sleep deprived yeah and then he
went when as soon as he called his wife
when he went outside and she was like I
want you to listen and say out loud
again what you just said to me yeah
they're making fun of you cuz they you
believe in sasquatches you're right he's
like mad about it like there was also a
lot of yeah we're gonna Hollywood good
locations [ __ ] sucks and he'd been
working there for four days straight
yeah we uh I haven't left yet [ __ ]
he's still powering it down that's how
he likes it he's good lashing it yeah I
don't miss it I don't miss it either I
don't miss it at all good people but I
do not miss I don't need hours
everything else is fine the hours are a
[ __ ] obviously for me was a
little bit different yeah what I don't
miss is just people just found it too
easy to [ __ ] on you cuz you're just one
step removed from the system in their
minds uh-huh like that that was the
thing when when I went back and did that
sports nagar thing at the end of the
night me and a buddy Joe that John knows
and then uh uh I invited him to go grab
a drink oh you are not yeah yeah and one
of the and one of the line producers
came with and then we're just we're just
out wrapping it up you know having a
drink and start [ __ ] on me for like
what did you really do on this show
you're not you don't understand what you
do right except other except just you
know cost us a lot of money and off line
producer go that's like no dude you're
chillin line but but it reminded me
that's why I don't want to [ __ ] do
that job anymore because they don't
respect anything you know I you know
they don't respect the decisions that
you had to make do
get them to that spot right where they
could do the things they needed to do
there they don't see any of that [ __ ]
they just they just look at you and go
you're annoying there yeah they see that
costs money but then they are also
catching it yeah they're right you're
right here they're right here but then
like all these people are raining the
same what did you actually do your
[ __ ] 4 y-o-u watch the budget oh
thanks buddy like ScarJo just went into
tears on cue the [ __ ] did you do ScarJo
was she involved in that no no it's a
reference also details are important in
punch line I tried to ignore that aspect
of it because i knew i was also still
working as a comedian but there was one
time where I was sitting in the chair
work in the elevator where dhire roldan
you know this comic dhire I do know a
working on the pot movie that never came
out probably and I'm just sitting there
and I'm like yo what's up T race I good
you doing all right like I'm smiling I'm
saying hello and you're asking me if I'm
doing are you know I didn't like that he
ever point was using the point of
reference quest right that's what he was
doing right Hey look I'm sitting in a
chair just like you honest and around
said just like you what's the [ __ ]
difference he may have begin paid about
$16 he was he was a difference yeah so
anything else Johnny oh uh alright well
you know how like some people like I
have a theory that there's only like
five or ten real faces in the world and
then the rest of you know we all kind of
the way DNA is set up like last episode
I brought on my friend Mike whose father
passed away Matt and Mike could be
brothers yeah it happens they looked
like I got a friend I got a friend who
everybody thinks is my brother yeah and
he lives here now and we just roll with
it now we don't feel like explaining it
there is a side-by-side app you guys got
to use it that's what you do when things
look the same like I sent you the
bobblehead guy and you didn't I there
you know the the red-bearded bobblehead
guy from the Oakland A's Sean Doolittle
yeah sure well you know I thought that'd
be you get excited maybe there was a
thought it was just know that River but
i like i like doin side-by-sides if I
see someone looks like you went to side
by side you almost wonder one night he
just kept sending me like Rick Sutcliffe
next to my face and like all these
baseball players next to me and I was
like yeah I guess I kind of look like
those people to dip in your mouth John I
didn't have anything else to do that
night yeah Oh clearly clearly i'm just
saying sot when you're bored you were
talking about or the line producers i
well i sent some pictures of John hog
yeah i did a side-by-side enjoy did it I
did it air side by side besides what do
you want from me yeah Emma side by side
got ya Brian early but I do Sabah be so
great if that causes a bar fight it's so
hard to keep you cool as an adult it's
just a little thing but you still want
to punch the guy in the face right in
the [ __ ] face he's got the nerve he's
got the [ __ ] nerve and he's testing
he's testing the physical world when it
does something like that luckily I don't
have a punch I'm on the the bumble app
right now do you guys know what that is
I don't it's like tinder do you know
what that is I know what ten days just
like tinder and um and this girl there's
no oh you're a comedian she says like
two girls said something like it's so
important to like laugh and have a good
attitude that's so good your committee
and I didn't I spared her the reality
yeah yeah let her let her live that
sheltered life there for a little while
longer there's such few laps and such
few good attitude yeah I was like mine
that's what you think you should have
texted her baggage is that we're not
dating on stage yeah we'll be dating in
reality yeah and you need there's no
laughs analogy all right no I just
didn't write her back yeah that's enough
reality who did you do it and here you
go yeah I never actually want to meet
anybody on these dating apps I went out
why are you on them because you just you
get tired of Instagram and Twitter and
Facebook you're using it that way like
you're looking at stuff to entertain
yourself yeah it's like oh cuz like
Instagram you like I'll never [ __ ] these
girls but then like bumble you're like
yeah if they match up like just a
possibility so that's what it is but
I've gotten down to the point where it's
I only like swipe or swipe right on
girls and that means give the thumbs up
to girls that are like like just way out
of my league so that means I know man
I'm not real date I think some of them
might be you can tell when they're not
real that's when you match up with them
and they try to [ __ ] you that night
that's you're like ok so when you swipe
right you're see what does that really
mean though they're sending a message
back to them say enjoy that person
sure it doesn't go back to them I don't
think you both have the options two
thumbs up or thumbs down on somebody and
you don't know that somebody gives you
thumbs up until until you give them a
thumbs up you have to both give thumbs
up before you know that you like each
other which is all when you look at
someone's picture you don't know if
they've given you a thumbs up or thumbs
down you're in the dark but or you're
gonna get my thumbs up you don't eyelet
like I am which sometimes the lights are
off cuz I poop in the dark yeah but so
let's say okay I get that but let's say
you hit the thumbs up and then you never
get a response back from you just don't
know you know you know no not a sick as
she doesn't know that you gave her the
thumbs up and unless she clicks on you
gives you a thursday so you know she do
you don't know no ultimately you know
they didn't give you the thought that's
what it doesn't mean they saw your
picture oh yeah because it's all based
on gps and where you are it's all
shuffled accordingly okay so yeah they
definitely didn't give you the thumbs up
but that doesn't mean that hey check out
that doesn't mean that they saw it and
yeah yeah see ya they weren't like on
RuPaul's and they and oh and they don't
know that you gave them the thumbs up
because they didn't give you the
thumbs-up to see your thumbs up what I
and that's how the connection works it
has to be to be nearby and but the
thumbs ups out that's what ultimately
supposed to be for gay people who watch
bubble well good uses Twitter grindr
reinders was oh so women so they're all
the same they're all the same idea oh
but when it was gay guys it was it was
based on location because it's like
let's go hook up oh it really be you
could go on there and be people in
tender Trump's is nothing but women
ruining a great gay hookup app no guys
they're just like they all day right is
there are two things they're like
they're bitching you out from the get-go
they're like no guys to do this on 5 11
you better have manners you better know
how to spell it's like you know spell 38
and divorced tion you don't have any
[ __ ] stipulations you know um I do
now where I'm just like if I cook at the
person really really I don't do it
willy-nilly anymore because it leads to
going out on dates it really does so you
have you know which I'll have you used
I've used tinder and bubble bumbles
better what's that I saved you the
details I didn't think we can talk that
much about it but i want i can never use
it neither can even i'm curious as to
bumble is better
because the women once you match up the
women have to go first with the
messaging which makes them way more
comfortable okay so you can't contact
them so if you match up on tinder you
really a [ __ ] what's up is that they're
already annoyed they're already in
control but if they're the ones reaching
out and they're the ones that even the
first message then yeah they're
comfortable contacting so you've gone
away in contact so tender your first
tinder one yes oh this is always the
question though right I've gone on three
of these dates and they've all been good
days okay but but our people truthful in
how I describe themselves make sure is
not even in their picture none of an all
three of them we're not true pictures
are you are you if you look at your
picture would you go yeah that's me yeah
I think so okay so but all three of them
like but how far off base are we talking
about here in respects to when you
finally meet them how far off base of
who they said they were were you really
dealing with their description of the
songs I said the way they usually look a
little older or a little plumper okay
because girls know how to take good
pictures of themselves yes and here's
who you don't want to spite ripe on
right on somebody only takes a picture
of their face you know this from the
myspace day yeah yeah yeah and upward
just picture the face or you know if
it's like a half off the face or like if
it's upside down they know all the
tricks one time I try to take a picture
of some girls like from below and they
all what no no no you got sick from
above it like makes them look thinner or
better or something yeah they know all
this [ __ ] cuz that it cuz like how many
times they've met like dane cook or
whatever they're like I'm ugly I can't
even post it like it's a big deal every
picture has to look good because every
pictures going to the general public but
so here's the thing though obviously it
because it goes both ways right it's
like somebody let's say oh well Matt
that's not cool for you to say so you're
not interested in a girl that's a little
bit heavier set but then on the [ __ ]
wrong with it no no I'm saying but on
the flip side you can say like well yeah
but you're also misrepresented you I'm
not seeing who you said you were so if
you're if you're not ashamed of being a
little humper why are you not showing
that yeah if you want a light
conversation when you just meet somebody
yeah sure I just get drunk and roll with
[ __ ] it's usually very fun of the three
of the three yeah what did any of them
right out of the box disappoint you so
much that you're like I gotta get no
[ __ ] out of here no okay alright so
that's okay at the end of the day
perfectly acceptable okay but um to Jos
touch with any of them yes helmet how
many of the 31 okay so you're you bet
you're betting uh was it 333 I'm not
good with math it's about a 33-percent
yeah you're getting one success rate we
were doing one third of three ah that's
right and which one was it was it number
one number temporary number two okay so
what was your intent sorry I'm intrigued
by this whole kick goes outside of Mike
my room I've been on I'm not probably
not gonna talk to anybody for the rest
of the day listen beat this is this is
I'm very Shandling this is the takeaway
of this show yeah don't talk this is the
takeaway of this show right they people
get to learn about these things sure
that's what I'm telling myself dating
websites and [ __ ] it dude it'sit's out
you're out I'm out this is what people
do now this is what Matt does well yeah
not more but now he's using an Instagram
but um so it's so you go out with number
one it was your intent hook up or you
just really give a [ __ ] you never really
give a [ __ ] like where's your head at
you like you're I don't you I don't care
about sex anymore okay at all happy to
have it okay happy if it goes dude
that's not that is not going in you're
like all right I'm going out with this
chick tonight let's hope not only that
I'm like oh I don't even think I want to
go like I get real nervous okay I don't
want to go do it I go to usually it's
like you know my conversation skills
have developed immensely you get older
you get better at certain things sure
well you asked a lot of more information
to pull from avatar talk about two sure
and they usually I'm there was never the
first one was fine like she she was fun
to talk to she was like funny like you
know it went it went very well anyway we
made out a little bit afterwards okay
and all these people are they all
working women that want to meet somebody
like you because you're not like a
traditional working dude either like
that's that's I'm curious as to what
kind of world
depending on who you are that might be
an appeal right um two of the dates are
in New York and I think that's kind of
more impressive out there because
everyone has a real job out there so
these women work day they were they had
a careers and all that stuff yeah
absolutely where do they fall age-wise
um early 30s for the first one late 20s
for the second one late 30s for the
third one okay yeah and which one did
you have the best time with 0 the older
person cuz you had more to talk about it
has nothing to do with the one you had
sex with oh yeah there was moving sex
from that one but how did he get to the
sexes in you guys you guys gel chatter
no we have sex on the first date oh oh
yeah okay but so that's the best-case
scenario right there was the second one
was a 28 year old water whatever reason
wasn't wasn't annoying uh-huh or anyways
uh not shoot its cool the other two you
only live once yeah yeah now is that a
mutual sometimes or how do you end
[ __ ] dates well um you know it
depends it's just like any other day
it's like you kept I don't know what is
that like that's what I just went out
with on sunday i could tell she gotta
tell she was like fine with me i was
like oh this is fine we were both
calling others fine and she was and uh
and she just like kind of split and i
was like cool she gave me a kiss on the
cheek and we was both we're both kinda
like this is fine see you this was here
in LA yah where were you where do you
guys go where'd you guys or where did
you end we said I guy only I only do
bars okay uh because I have to drink
through these things I'm not I'm not
gonna make any [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie
I can't do this [ __ ] sober no way uh
doesn't change when you get married and
have kids either what do you mean well
you can't go to the bar you just do it
within the house right now you just have
a couple when you know you need them um
it's always good to have a portable bar
within the house um oh and also because
and my first tinder date was really cool
she was I told her about this place she
goes yeah I go I go yeah they got great
food there too Sheila hey hey hey hey
hey we're not doing dinner we're not
like doing dinner I go oh I know we're
not doing dinner I'm we're going to a
bar and if you want to eat something
they got that too like forget it
you gotta have I'm not sitting across
the table from somebody I don't know
where there's um I guess you could just
leave not as the man you can't just
leave you responsible for paying so I
like to go to a bar there's there's easy
out for both people you not fit if there
is an uncomfortable silence you can look
at a game and go hey look at this dick
on TV like like to just staring into
each other's faces I'm just not doing
that ever again I don't care if I die
alone in Malibu so how long hey now hey
why's he gotta die this is oh so I so
they could be really short then too cuz
you could you got if it doesn't work out
after like one drink the shortest that's
the thing about the bar right we're just
entered her trapped you're saying yeah
you're trapped definitely for a couple
just too formal yeah in an informal
world where we just met on the goddamn
yeah [ __ ] world wide web so was the LA
one short it was it was relatively short
but it was still only it was still
lasted like two hours ok and she wishes
s two hours of conversation with a
stranger that's pretty good yeah and she
in the end she was like I'm gonna head
out it was nice to meet you she's like
they have food here and I'm like telling
her about she's like yeah I go they got
this next door they got this next to get
this next to her and she goes yeah
that's cool she goes you know what I
really want to do though she's telling
me like all about this like this is like
Mexican whole foods and she's like
starts talking about I go you know what
go do it I was like I'm not gonna
[ __ ] keep you here that's what you
want to do you go do it and it was not a
big deal it sounds like a big deal none
of them saying it yeah I go I'm the same
way I only want to eat exactly what i
want to eat and a few minds on that like
just go do it Jenny we were kicking her
to the curb no or you thought she just
wanted out I r you don't even give a
[ __ ] either way she's still hung around
for another half an hour I could tell it
wasn't I could tell is like very
friendly ok but there wasn't like a huge
connection ok that's my version of it
could be a different version right if
you're sticking around for two hours and
you don't split right away and you don't
go now come on let's go next door then
then everybody's doing exactly what they
want to and no one's really mad at each
other ok she got some free drinks I
always pay ok I'm a goddamn gentlemen I
found out that that's not necessarily
the case real i always bring cash money
the no games goin
electronic swiping issues me [ __ ]
cash money laid down I always pay first
date which is bad like I got into the
one she said that President and I think
they're you're always paying but
whatever I didn't give you that makes me
feel good actual is modern dating
splitsies I don't even know we moderate
a Nicole did you what was your what was
your thing ever always oh yeah yeah but
but dude in New York City with the
drinking scene in the social scene there
I was talking to this girl I went out
with on the second tender day and one of
her friends she you know this was later
she brought say oh I thought she brought
a safety no she didn't ring a safety
this is later and they're both like yeah
you know like it's crazy that you pay
it's even crazy that you have cash like
that's some old man [ __ ] but they always
take cash unless you [ __ ] yeah unless
a couple miles in the air they always
take cash it's an old man [ __ ] leave you
wear sandals in black socks or the idea
that you have money to pay for what
you're gonna consume like this is the
money I'm bringing to take care of this
transaction I took pride in it man yeah
[ __ ] that feels good boom well this
is good to know i was fascinated by that
whole I don't find I don't find it fun I
just find it like actually I find it fun
it's like it's like doing stand-up or
anything else like leading up to it
you're like oh god I don't want to do
this but once it actually starts once
you grab the mic or she grabs the mic
everything's fine everything's [ __ ]
fine and you can bail you can't do this
is you always think you gotta do certain
things yeah you can run for the [ __ ]
hills well I like the concept of it not
being dinner cuz I think that gives it
makes it more like listen let's not
[ __ ] here's the downside of that like
you date goes well you mention their
drinking yeah I can't do anything I
gotta go home your mouth stops were yeah
yeah yeah yeah you dicks not a better
class work ah better to know what you're
really like that right yeah exactly i
guess that's the truth dude thanks sir
thanks for coming oh my pleasure um
welcome back to town of you you [ __ ] no
I don't like show again eighty podcasts
already I sure it's the back in a week
and a half I so next time we see each
other I will have
Ben fact speaking Cleveland when I first
asked you I'll be back from rockauto all
the kids are rocking hoorah okay I would
just want and to canton canada goes
through the pro football how cool a
little family trip me in the way kids
yeah you guys got a lot of work to do
yeah well that's your the kids the Hall
of rapists have you been you went to the
rock roll hall of fame yeah just too
will they be interested enough there's
enough there to interest them right I
would hope so again i'm an old man I'm
like this is amazing its flavor flav's
clock whose Flavor Flav found that
there's gonna be some of that is a
mickeys disco album know that they can
stare out for doom okay well we'll
figure it out all right John anything
else ah no man thanks for doing the show
appreciate it a lot of fun thanks for
listening everybody Oh full charge power
hour yes full charge power hour at the
full charge on Twitter do it and what do
you want bumble Matt 41 big on big horny
balls 41 thanks that's the thing I put
my own age to I do I keep it real sorry
I know you're ending thank you for
listening to Hollywood anonymous don't
forget to follow us on twitter at
hollywood and nany that is short for
Hollywood anonymous you can also follow
John individually at John Huck and
myself Brian or when at Brian or went on
Twitter as well both of us can be found
on facebook you can also google us and
contact us directly hollywood anonymous
guys at gmail.com thank you again so
much for listening and please don't
forget to subscribe
you